ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
เรียมวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะ
ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 28 ค่ะผู้หญิง
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพตอะไรคะ
พ.ศ
ปีขอศ.อะไรคะข้อ 2 ต.ค 2012
ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่ 4 โมงคะครูเรียมตอนนี้
9:00 น 29 นาทีค่ะคุณหญิงค่ะ 9 โมง 29
นาทีนคู่เรี่ยมกินข้าวห้อง
สุขากินข้าวเช้าหรือยัง 9 โมงแล้วเนี่ย
ยังยังไม่ได้กินเลยค่ะครูหญิง
ผู้หญิงกินข้าวเช้าหรือยังรู้หรอคะ
ผู้หญิงยังไม่ได้กินเหมือนกันหิวเข่า
อิงค์ผิวมากเลย
เอ้าคู่เรียมหิวแล้วทำไมไม่กินข้าว
เงียบก็คิดคิดอยู่ว่าจะกิน
พิซซ่าหนูจะกินแซนวิช
pizza แซลลี่ผมซ่าเลยเหรอคะตอน Z
ถ้า
ใช่ขอขอบคุณ
เองยังเลือกไม่หรอว่าจะกินอะไรดียังลังเล
อยู่เหรอครับว่าจะกินอะไรเป็นอาหารเช้าดี
ใช่ค่ะยังลังเลลังเลมั่งแต่ 7:00 นแล้ว
ลังเลตั้งแต่ 07:00 นถึง 9:30 นณตอนนี้
ลังเลมา 2 ชั่วโมงครึ่งแล้วยังเลือกไม่
ได้ว่าเช้านี้จะกินอะไรดีนะ
ใช่น่าจะแบบนี้ไปกินครั้งเดียวตอน 12:00
นเดี๋ยวมา
กิ่วหิวหิวแล้วก็ไม่เลือก
แล้วปกติเนี่ยครูเรียมเป็นคน
หลักเรไหมเป็นหรือเปล่าว่าเลือกไม่ค่อย
ได้ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะเป็นคนที่แบบ
เลือกไม่ได้หรือขึ้นรักแล้วนักเลงเยอะมาก
ๆลังเลกับหลายๆอย่าง
ดีบ้างอ่ะครูเรียมขนาดรองเท้านะรองเท้า
ที่เหลี่ยมใส่นี่
ค่ะ
ใส่ไปวิ่งนะแล้วมันหลับขาดอ่ะค่ะมันขาด
กับใส่ไม่ได้แล้วใช่ไหมคะมันขายได้แล้ว
เรียนก็เลยจะไปซื้อไปซื้อรองเท้าคู่ใหม่
หนึ่งก็จะเดินเดินเดินดู
แล้วก็แบบที่คู่นี้พรุ่งนี้ก็สวยนะ
ผู้นี่รองเท้าวิ่งเข้าเป็นแบบนี้ไหมอ่ะ
ต่อไปรองเท้าบูทนะ
อ่าแค่นี้รองเท้าวิ่งนะคะน้องใช่พรุ่งนี้
สวย
สวยมากพรุ่งนี้ก็
สวยค่ะมีแบบ 2 คู่เนี้ย 1  2 เดือน
ชอบผู้นี้ชอบผู้นี้ลังเล
ซื้อคู่ไหนดีเหยี่ยว
คู่เรียมเลือกไม่ได้เพราะว่ามันดูแล้ว
เนี่ยสีไม่เหมือนกันหรือว่าเลือกไม่ได้
แบบลังเลว่าไอ้จะเอา Nike  Adidas
Nike  Adidas ยี่ห้อไม่เหมือนกันค่ะ
ยิ่งเหมือนกัน
อันนี้ก็ Nike  Adidas
ต่อก็สวยสีสวยกับมันเหมือนกันเราก็แล้วก็
ใส่ดีเหมือนๆกันใช่ไหมลองแล้วก็แบบนิ่ม
โอ๊ยน่าจะวิ่งได้ดีทั้งผู้
ใช่นกหญิงไหมบางทีถ้าเกิดเตรียมลังเล
ลังเลมากๆเรียนก็ไม่เอาไม่ซื้อไม่ซื้อก็
ซื้อไม่เอาอะไรเลยไม่เอา
แล้วก็ไม่ได้อะไรเลย
การทุเรียนก็ไม่มีรองเท้าใส่วิ่งสิคะไม่
มีรองเท้าใส่วิ่งก็เลยเหรอคะโอเคเดี๋ยว
วันวัดหาดไปแล้วกันวันต่อไปอาจจะเป็นวัน
พรุ่งนี้เดี๋ยวก็ไปดูหน่อยอาจจะมีรองเท้า
ที่แบบชอบชอบมากๆ
ฝรั่งเลย์
นี้นอกจากจะมีมาอีกคู่หนึ่ง
รองเท้าไม่คู่หนึ่งที่แบบคือผู้ที่ฝากมี
อะไร
สวยมาก
สวยมากกว่า
มากกว่า 2 คู่นี้สวยมากๆเลยเนี่ยโอเคเอา
คู่นี้ซื้อ
โทรหาแบบมันจะมีคนที่ลังเลแบบครูเรียม
เนี้ยถ้ามันมี 2 คู่คิดว่ามีสนามนาไม่
เท่าไหร่เน๊าะจะทำมันเหลือ 2 คู่แล้วอ้ะ
มันจะเป็นคนที่แบบเลือกไม่ได้ก็จะเหมือน
คู่เรียนก็คือเลือกไม่ได้ก็ไม่ซื้อ
หรือบางคนเนี่ยลังเลใช่ไหมแบบเลือกไม่ได้
ว่าไอ้เจ้าคู่นี้คู่นี้คู่นี้ดีเจาะซื้อ 2
คู่เลยผู้หญิงเป็นแบบก็จะมี 2 แบบ
ที่ 2 เวลาเวลาเลือกอยากได้ผู้หญิงก็จะ
แบบ
อันนี้ก็สวยกูจะเป็นมากๆกับเสื้อเสื้อยืด
เหนื่อยอ่ะแบบบางทีมันโสดใส่ Isuzu ลาย
เหมือนกันอย่างนี้แล้วกับโอ้ยสีขาวก็สวย
สีฟ้าแต่ก็สวย
เรื่องไม่ได้อ้ะจะซื้อ 2 สีเลย
น่าจะเป็นแบบนี้มากกว่าแต่จะไม่ค่อยเป็น
กับรองเท้ารองเท้าเนี่ยไม่ค่อยรองเท้า
สำหรับค่อนข้างไม่ค่อยลังเลนะคะเลือกได้
เลยซื้อได้เลยแล้วครูเรียมมีเรื่องอื่น
เรื่องอื่นที่แลปทุเรียนลังเลอีกไหมคะที่
เป็นบ่อยๆใช่ป่ะเลือกไม่ได้อ้ะมีค่ะเวลา
ที่เรียมเข้าไปในคาเฟ่
ไอคาเฟ่
เรียมก็จะชอบชอบดื่มช็อกโกแลตไม่ใช่
ช็อกโกแลตโกโก้
อา
โกโก้และอีกอันนึงก็จะเป็นก็ร้อนโกโก้
ร้อน
ค่ะอีกหนึ่งก็จะเป็นชาชา
เวลาที่เข้าไปในร้านแล้วเขาถามรับอะไรดี
คะนี่ก็คิดวันนี้โกโก้ร้อน
หรือว่าชาร้อนกูก็ร้อนหรือว่าชาร้อนเมื่อ
วานนี้ก็ดื่มโกโก้
หรือว่าวันนี้จะดื่มชา
ก็ชอบโกโก้นะก็กินคิดอยู่คนเดียวที่อยู่
คนเดียวเพราะลำเลแล้ว Q  Q  Q ข้างหลัง
ยาวไหมยาวคิวข้างหลังก็ยาวคนข้างหลังก็
มองทำอะไร
ผู้หญิงคนนี้เลือกได้รึยังนะจ๊ะเนื้อเพลง
อีกนานไหม
[เพลง]
ใช่บางทีเด่นด้วยแหละเอากบก็ร้อนค่ะเราก็
ไปดื่มดื่มแล้วก็
เอาเอาช้าร้อนด้วยดีกว่าก็เลยดื่ม 2
อย่างเลย
ก็ไม่นอนเลยนี้
เหมือนเมื่อคืน
ไม่รู้เรื่องไม่รู้
เออ
หรือว่าบางคนก็จะเป็นแบบนี้ไหมว่าถ้า
สมมติว่ามีเวลาอย่างคุยอันนี้ก็ไม่เคย
เป็นนะแต่ไม่รู้ว่ามันเขามีคนเป็นไหมแบบ
ว่าบางครั้งเรามีเวลาแค่แบบประมาณ 3
ชั่วโมงและเราอยากดูหนังว่าภาคอะอยากดู
หนังใช่ไหมแล้วมันมีหนัง 2 เรื่องมีอาวุธ
มีอะไรกับช่วงนี้เขามีหนังเรื่องอะไรบ้าง
คะอะไรเหยี่ยวไลท์เยียร์หรอบาสไลท์เยียร์
แล้วก็
เอลวิสดรอปผู้หญิงเห็นนะไม่รู้นะสมมุติมี
หนัง 2 เรื่อง Right  Here กับเอลวิสแบบ
ดูทั้ง 2 เรื่องเลยอ่ะกับอะไรดีนะ
อันนี้ก็คุณเรียมคือเป็นมั้ยเลือกไม่ได้
อ่ะว่าแบบจะดูหนังเรื่องอะไรดี
ผู้หญิงแล้วไม่ค่อยเป็นอ่ะ
เป็นคิดไปเลยจะไม่ค่อยลังเลจะดูหนังเลือก
ได้ไม่มีปัญหารอเพราะมีแค่เรียงคนเดียว
หรอที่รักเลย์ทั้งนี้รวมเป็นหรอ
เวลาดูหนังก็เป็นนะอย่างนี้ค่ะมันดีดีเธอ
จะมีเวลานิดเดียวนะ
ก็จะหาคือดูคลิปคลิปนี้หมดไปแล้ว 20 นาที
ใช้เวลาคิดหน่อยปวดเวลา 20 นาที
เรื่องไหนเราจะดูเรื่องอะไรดี
ถ้าเกิดแบบไม่คิดนะไม่ลังเลนะอาจจะดูได้ 2
ค่ะอาจจะดูดิ่
ใช้เวลาเราว่า
บางครั้งก็เรื่องยากนะที่แบบว่าจะดู
เรื่องอะไรดีนะเรื่องนี้ก็น่าดูเรื่องนี้
ก็สนุกเรื่องนี้ก็ก็เอกหล่อมากเลยโอ้อยาก
ดูไม่รู้จะเลือกเลือกไม่ถูกนะคะอ่าจะยัง
ไม่ได้เนาะก็คิดอ่ะโอเคเดี๋ยววันนี้ดู
เรื่องนี้ก่อน
กะอาจจะ uavs  God แล้วถ้าเกิดแบบมีเวลา
ในพรุ่งนี้หรือวันอะไรก็เป็นภาษาเดี๋ยวไป
ดูอีกเรื่องคะ
พี่ใช่เขาก็ลังเลอยู่ดี
ก็ลำรี
ใช่แปลว่าครูเรียนก็น่าจะเป็นคนที่แบบก็
มีคำนี้ไหม
ขี้ลังเล
ภาษาไทยมีไหม
ที่รักเหมือนกัน
ค่ะว่าเรื่องมากเลือก
เลือกมากๆเลือกไม่ได้อ้ะมันควรจะเกิด
ขึ้นผู้หญิงเนี่ยไม่ค่อยเป็นเพราะว่า
เป็นคนชอบอะไรเหมือนเดิมอ่ะสมมุติว่า
อย่างคนเรียนบอกว่า
คุณเรียมเลือกไม่ได้ว่าจะอะไรใช่ไหมคะ
ช็อกโกแลตร้อนหรือชาร้อนอย่างเงี้ยถ้า
เป็นผู้หญิงก็จะมีอะไรจูผิดชอบช็อกโกแลต
มากแต่วันก็อยากจะดื่มชานะแล้วถ้ามัน
เลือกไม่ถ้าใช่ก็จะเลือกอะไรที่เราชอบ
เนี่ยก็คือแบบก็เลยเป็นคนที่แบบว่าไม่
ค่อยก็มีปัญหาน่าจะเลือกอะไรเนี่ยว่าจะ
เลือกเหมือนเดิมกับเธอก็เลย
สมมติสมมติอย่างที่เที่ยวอเมริกาใช่ไหมคะ
อาหารเนี่ยเขาจะเสิร์ฟมา 1 จานมันใหญ่มาก
ๆมันใหญ่มากอย่างนี้เราบางครั้งเวลาที่
เราไปร้านอาหารสมคือเราเป็นคนไทยเนาะเรา
ก็จะคิดถึงอาหารไทยอ่ะค่ะแล้วเวลาที่เรา
ไปร้านอาหารไทยอ่ะแล้วเราอยากกิน 2 อย่าง
อยากกิน 2 อย่างมากๆแบบสมมติอย่างวันนั้น
ถึงไปร้านอาหารใช่ไหมคะก็อยากกินส้มตาม
ช่วงจำก็อยากกินผัดซีอิ้วก็อยากกินแต่เรา
สั่ง 2 อย่างไม่ได้
มันใช่มากมันกินไม่หมดไงเออใช่มาเสิร์ฟมา
ใหญ่มากแล้วก็
ก็เรียกไม่ได้คิดกินอะไรดีกินอะไรดีกิน
อะไรดีอย่างนี้ก็อ่ะโอเคเราอยากกินผัด
ซีอิ้วตั้งแต่เมื่อวานนี้แต่เรามาเห็นส้ม
ตำในร้านแล้วเราเห็นคนอื่นกินแล้วเราอ่ะ
กินสมัยแบบถ้าเรามี Choice ที่มันเลือก
ไม่ได้เราก็จะคุยกันจะกินเลยว่าฉันอยาก
กินกับซีอิ้งฉันอยากกินผัดซีอิ้วฉันอยาก
กินซีอิ้วก็จะบอกตัวเองก็เลยเหรอเป็นคน
ที่ไม่ค่อยลังเลเลอหน้า
ถ้าเกิดเรียนเลือกครั้งหนึ่งแล้วอ่ะครั้ง
ต่อไปเรียนก็จะเลือกอันเดิมนะเหมือน
อันเนี้ยผู้หญิงโทรศัพท์เนี่ยอะไรคะ
โทรศัพท์ EM เพื่อแล้วก็ใช้มันนานมากแล้ว
วันนึงอ้ะมันแตกข้างหลังแตก
ค่ะเรียงขึ้นไปหาซื้อรุ่นเดิมมา
เธอมาเปลี่ยนไม่เปลี่ยนก็เพราะว่าครั้ง
หนึ่งก็คือเลือกแล้วไง
แล้วซื้อเครื่องใหม่ก็เหมือนเดิม
ยังไงถ้าเป็นแบบเรื่องเล็กๆน้อยๆเรื่อง
นี้จะกิจนาไรจะดื่มอะไรดีนะอะไรผู้เตรียม
จับค่อนข้างเลือกไม่ได้สมัยแบบจะลังเลจะ
คิดนานมากว่าแบบอะไรดีนะอะไรดีนะใช่เรามี
หลายครั้งที่ยืมแบบลังเลมากๆเวลาซื้อรอง
เท้าอ่ะกันเรียงก็จะเข้าไปถามอะมีคู่แบบ
นี้ไหมคะแบบที่เดิมกำลังใส่อยู่ค่ะเขาก็
คือ
หมดแล้วค่ะ
เพราะว่าแบบนี้อยากเรื่องมากแล้วนะคะใช่
แบบไม่อยากเลือกเพราะรู้ว่าตัวเองเนี่ย
เป็นคนที่ลังเลแล้วก็แบบแถวหน้านามก็เลย
แบบเอาเหมือนเดิมเนี่ยเอาคู่นี้เหมือน
เดิมได้อุ้ยเขาให้บอกไม่มีแล้วค่ะมันหมด
แล้ว
อ่ะเอาอีกและถึงเวลาที่เรียนต้องลังเล
เลือกผู้ไหนไม่ได้
ใช่เหนื่อยมากเลยนะเวลาที่
แล้วเวลาคุณเรียมเป็นคนขับรถใช่ไหมคะคือ
แบบอันนี้คือผู้หญิงอ่ะไม่ไม่ได้เป็นคน
อ่าขับรถไม่เป็นน้องขับรถไม่เป็นนะคะแต่
แบบเหมือนแบบเขาก็บอกว่ามันเคยได้ยินมานะ
เขาบอกว่าเวลาที่เราขับรถเนี่ยเราจะลังเล
ไม่ได้ต้องต้องตัดสินใจอ่ะถั่วมันต้อง
เลือกเลยอ่ะค่ะว่าถ้าเราจะตรงก็คือตรงนะ
แต่ว่าเราจะเลี้ยวก็คือเลี้ยวเสื้อไหม
เพราะว่าบางคนเนี่ยขับรถแล้วก็คิดเราจะ
ตรงไปดีไหมนะเดี๋ยวเราจะเลี้ยวดีเพราะบาง
ครั้งอ่ะที่ที่เราจะไปมันอาจจะมี 2 ทาง
คือตรงไปและก็ได้เลี้ยวเลี้ยวซ้ายก็ได้
แต่ถ้าเราลังเลอ่ะแบบนี้เราจะตรงไปแล้วก็
เลี้ยวซ้ายตรงไปเลี้ยวซ้ายตรงไปเลี้ยว
ซ้ายเนี่ยก็ไม่ได้ใช่ไหมเวลาที่เราขับรถ
ว่าคันข้างหลังก็จะแบบบีบแตรหรืออาจจะชน
กันได้
เรียนเวลาขับรถนะไม่ได้รู้สึกลังเลนะ
เพราะในคนที่ขับรถแบบเร็วมาก
ใช่ค่ะแบบได้คิดคิดไว้ก่อนว่าจะไปไหนถ้า
เกิดลังเลเนี่ยลังเลตอนคิดมากกว่าว่าจะไป
ไหนดีจะไปน่านไอ้หรือว่าไปภูเก็ตจะไปนั่ง
ไปภูเก็ตถ้าเกิดแบบเอ่อเมย์แล้วก็เลือก
แล้วเอาไปภูเก็ตก็จะขับรถไปภูเก็ตเลยก็จะ
ไม่ไม่ได้ลังเลเกี่ยวกับว่าต้องซ้ายหรือ
ขวา size กว่าเพลงมาแบบเหมือนเคยบ่เคยเคย
นั่งรถอ่ะเนาะวันนั้นให้สีอะไรเงี้ยค่ะ
แล้วแบบแท็กซี่เค้าก็จะเค้าขับรถทุกวัน
ใช่ไหมเขาก็จะแบบเหมือนคนเดียวไงอ้ะเค้า
จะเก่งอ่ะเนาะในเรื่องของการขับรถและบาง
ครั้งเขาก็จะแบบจะเลี้ยวหรือจะตรงกับรถชน
ช่วงหน้าเนี้ยบางทีแบบรถพบกับลังเลเลือก
ไม่ได้ว่าฉันจะตรงหรือว่าฉันจะรีบก็อย่าง
เงี้ยแท็กซี่ก็จะแบบช่วยเลือกได้ไหมเพราะ
ว่าแบบเขาจะได้รู้ว่าคุณก็คือตรงเนี้ยจะ
ตรงหรือจะเลี้ยวจะตรงหรือจะเลี้ยวคือคน
ที่ขับตามหลังมาเขาก็จะแบบอ่าเจอไม่โอเค
เรียบก็เคยเป็นเหมือนคันที่ขับตามข้าง
หลังมานั่นแหละแล้วก็ขัดตามแล้วเห็นรถคัน
ข้างหน้าจะไปทางไหน
จะไปถึงไหนคณะทำงานไหม
ไปไปทางนี้ก็ไปจับคะอันนี้ก็ไปนะอะไร
เนี่ยเออไม่ใช่เหลี่ยมและเวลาถ้าทำรู้
เนี่ยไม่ได้ล้างเลยมันอันตรายมาก
ใช่ค่ะใช่นั่นแหละผู้หญิงก็เคยได้ยิน
เปล่าว่าถ้าเราขับรถแล้วเราเป็นคนที่
ลังเลเหมือนกับไม่เลือกเร็วๆอ้ะมัน
อันตรายมากเลยเพราะว่ารถค่าหลังเขาไม่รู้
ไงอ่าว่าบางคันเนี่ยคิดแล้วก็จะตรงไปแต่
ก็เห็นตรงไปอู๊อู๋ข้างหน้ารถเยอะอยู่ดี
เลี้ยวเลยอย่างเงี้ยมันแบบมันลังเลอยู่
เออแล้วก็ตัดสินใจว่าโอเคฉันเลี้ยวแต่รถ
ข้างหลังเขามาเร็วไงเพราะเขาคิดว่าเราจะ
ตรงมันก็อาจจะแบบรถชนได้ก็คือแบบถ้าเรา
เป็นคนขับรถลังเลไม่ได้นะต้องเลือกเร็วๆ
ใช่ผู้หญิงดูไหมเริ่มเคยแบบขับรถไปแล้ว
มันจะมีที่ 3
แล้วมันจะมียูเทิร์นตรงนี้
ค่ะคือถนน
[เพลง]
เรียนนะขับรถอยู่ตรงนี้
แล้วมีรถคันข้างหน้าน่ะ
รถคันข้างหน้าเขาหยุดนะหยุดต่อหน้า
เหลี่ยมแล้วเขาก็คิดคิดว่าเขาจะไปทางนี้
หรือว่าจะยูเทิร์นเรียนก็แบบ
คือนำขับรถเร็วๆใช่ริมขับรถเร็วหน้าแล้ว
เขาก็แบบหยุดหยุดแบบอย่างเงี้ยด้วย
ตกใจ
ไม่ได้เดี๋ยวก็เรียนรู้เลยว่าเรียนจะเป็น
คนลังเลตอนขับรถแบบนี้ไม่ได้
ถ้าเกิดแบบทนน่ะ
ไม่ได้อันตรายมากหนูเสียเวลาก็แล้วนะ
ตอนนี้ก็หลายก็คือแต่
ว่าเรื่องอะเรียนก็ไม่ควรละมีนะ
ใส่ใจเราก็กำลังลังเลว่าเองเราจะกินอะไร
นี้นะตอนเช้าเราจะต้องไปกินข้าวแล้วนะฮะ
แต่ว่าลอง
วางเลย์ไหมหรือว่าเราจะเลือกทั้งสองอย่าง
ดีคุยเก่งในเพื่อคิดว่าก็คือกินไปด้วย
แล้วก็สอนไปด้วยเนี่ยเหรอคะให้คิดไม่ด้วย
สอนไปด้วยหรือว่าอยากกินพิซซ่ากับ
แซนด์วิชก็กินทั้ง 2 อย่างเลยไม่ต้อง
เลือกกินทั้ง 2 อย่างเลยใช่ค่ะอาหารเนี่ย
เวลาที่เราเลือกไม่ได้เราเลือกทั้งสอง
อย่างเลยนะคะว่ามันอร่อย
ทำไมเขาคุณเรียวผู้หญิงผู้หญิงโอเคโอเคก็
ได้ความรู้ไง
จะได้แบบไม่ต้องเลือกเยอะไงเลี้ยงก็บอก
อ๊อดเชื่อ
ก็ต้องกินสองชาย 3-4 แบบของบรรยาศถ้ามัน
ไม่แพงมากนอนไม่แพงสุดรองเท้าอย่างเงี้ย
รองเท้าเนี่ยมันแพงนะคะเราไม่สามารถซื้อ 2
คู่ได้อะนี้ไม่โอเคแต่ถ้าอาหารหรืออะไร
ที่แบบราคาแบบก็ถ้าเราเลือกไม่ได้ก็เลิก
สองอย่างเลยนะคะ
สบายใจใช่ไหมไม่ต้องคิดไม่ต้องลังเลบาง
อย่างไม่ต้องลังเลเลยค่ะเลือกเลยเหมือน
กับรถ
ดีมากเลยที่ได้มาคุยคุยเรื่องลังเลกับผู้
หญิง
จ่ายค่ะเราก็ไม่รู้ว่านักเรียนเนี่ยเป็น
คนลังเลหรือเปล่าเลือกไม่ได้หรือเปล่า
คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะคะหรือว่ากำลังลังเล
เรื่องอะไรอยู่พี่เจาะคอมเม้นท์บอกแล้วก็
ลังเลว่าจะมาประเทศไทยดีไหมนะมามีมามามา
หัวหน้ากำลังลังเลอยู่ก็ไม่ต้องรู้ไม่
ต้องลังเลนะคะอะเลยค่ะๆค่ะเรียกไงเปิด
แล้วนะคะเข้าใจแต่ว่าไม่ดีโอนี้หมดเวลา
แล้วใช่ไหมคะครูเรียมหมดเวลาแล้วค่ะคือ
ผู้หญิง
เราต้องลานักเรียนไปก่อนแล้ว
จ่ายเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้า
ใช่ค่ะไปแล้วค่ะผู้หญิง
สวัสดิ์นะคะบายค่ะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนได้ไหมอ่ะ